التاريخ مهم للتاريخ وتاريخ
الأسود مهم ، لا يمكنني فقط
اختيار معرفة ما نريد أن نعرفه ،
فنحن نتعلم ما يجب أن نعرفه علينا أن
نتعلم كل شيء جيد ، أو سيئ ،
الحقيقة ،
ومن نحن كأمة ، هذا ما تفعله
الأمم العظيمة ، وهذا ما
تفعله الأمم العظيمة ونحن أمة عظيمة ،
ولكن بالمناسبة ، فأنا لا أستطيع أن
أكون فتى أبيض ولكنني لست غبيًا ، فأنا أعرف
أين
القوة ، وأنا لا أعلم أين تكمن السيادة في أمريكا لن أمزح. التزام
الصمت الإنكار هو أسوأ ومن
غير المقبول أن نرى حيوية
الثقافة السوداء والتاريخ يثري
الحياة الأمريكية كلها في تاريخ الحياة الأمريكية
الذي لا يمكن دفنه لأنه
يعيش في روح هذه الأمة ، علينا
فقط أن نتذكر
[تصفيق]
عليك فقط أن تتذكر من
نحن الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية ،
لا يوجد شيء يتجاوز قدرتنا
لا شيء لا شيء